Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
¿Te han dicho alguna vez
que te pongas recto?
¿O regañado por estar
encorvado en una cena familiar?
Dichos comentarios pueden resultar
molestos pero están en lo cierto.
Tu postura, la manera en que sostienes
el cuerpo al estar sentado o de pie
es la base de todo movimiento
que produce tu cuerpo
y es definitiva para el grado
de adaptación a las tensiones.
Estas tensiones se crean
al llevar peso, por ejemplo,
o estar sentado en una
posición incómoda.
Y la mayor de todas que experimentamos
todos los días: la gravedad.
Si la postura de tu cuerpo
no es la óptima,
los músculos tienen que trabajar más
para mantenerlo erguido y equilibrado.
Algunos músculos se volverán
tensos y poco flexibles,
mientras que otros dejarán
de funcionar adecuadamente.
Con el tiempo, estas
adaptaciones disfuncionales
deteriorarán tu capacidad corporal
para hacer frente a las fuerzas
que actúan sobre ella.
La mala postura sigue desgastando
tus articulaciones y ligamentos,
aumenta la probabilidad de accidentes
y hace que algunos órganos como
los pulmones sean menos eficientes.
Los investigadores han relacionado
la mala postura a la escoliosis,
cefaleas
y dolor de espalda,
aunque no es la causa
exclusiva de todas ellas.
La postura puede influir
hasta en tu estado emocional
y en tu sensibilidad al dolor.
Así que hay muchas razones para
mantener una buena postura.
Pero cada vez es más difícil.
El estar sentado en un posición
incómoda durante mucho tiempo
puede crear el hábito
de una mala postura,
igual que el uso de las computadoras
o dispositivos móviles,
que obligan a mirar hacia abajo.
Muchos estudios sugieren que, en promedio,
la calidad de la postura está empeorando.
Entonces, ¿cual es una buena postura?
Si vemos la columna
desde el frente o por detrás,
los 33 vértebras deben aparecer
apiladas y en línea recta.
Al mirar de perfil, la columna
debe presentar tres curvas:
una en el cuello, una en los hombros,
y otra en la parte baja de la espalda.
No se nace con esta
columna en forma de "s".
La columna de un bebé solo tiene
una curva en forma de "c".
Las otras curvas, por lo general,
se desarrollan entre los 12 y 18 meses
mientras se fortalecen los músculos.
Estas curvas nos ayudan
a mantenernos rectos
y lidiar con parte de la tensión creada
por actividades como caminar y saltar.
Si están alineadas correctamente,
al estar de pie,
deberías poder dibujar una línea recta
desde un punto justo
delante de tus hombros,
y por detrás de la cadera
hasta la parte frontal de la rodilla
y a unos pocos centímetros
delante del tobillo.
Esto mantiene tu centro de gravedad
directamente sobre su base de apoyo,
lo que te permite moverte
de manera eficiente
y con la menor cantidad
de tensión muscular.
Si estás sentado, el cuello
debe mantenerse recto
no inclinado hacia adelante.
Los hombros deben estar relajados
con los brazos cerca del torso.
Las rodillas deben estar en ángulo recto
con los pies apoyados en el suelo.
Pero, ¿y si su postura
no es la correcta?
Intenta rediseñar tu entorno.
Ajusta la pantalla para que esté
a la misma altura de tus ojos
o ligeramente por debajo.
Asegúrate de que todas
las partes de tu cuerpo,
como los codos y las
muñecas están apoyados,
si es necesario, ergonómicamente.
Intenta dormir de lado,
con el cuello apoyado
y con una almohada entre las piernas.
Usa zapatos con poco tacón
y buen soporte para el arco de tu píe
y usa auriculares para
las llamadas telefónicas.
Pero mantener solo una buena
postura no es suficiente.
Mantener los músculos
y las articulaciones
en movimiento es
extremadamente importante.
De hecho, estar parado durante mucho
tiempo y mantener una buena postura
es peor que hacer movimiento
y mantener una mala postura.
Cuando te mueves,
hazlo con elegancia.
Mantén lo que estás llevando
cerca de tu cuerpo.
Las mochilas deben estar en contacto
con la espalda y llevadas simétricamente.
Si permaneces sentado mucho,
levántate y muévete a menudo
y asegúrate de hacer ejercicio.
La actividad muscular te mantendrá
suficientemente fuerte
para un mantenimiento corporal eficaz
además de todos los otros beneficios
para tus articulaciones,
huesos, cerebro y corazón.
Y si algo realmente te preocupa,
consulta con un terapeuta físico,
porque sí, de hecho,
deberías mantenerte recto.